[Music]
the average computer user has get this
27 passwords and as you probably know it
can be tough to keep track of all of
them but a solution may be at hand in
fact it may be in our hands think I have
more than 27 our devices themselves
contain sensors that can read all kinds
of identifying information about us and
that could make biometric data the key
to our online world putting an end to
the password
brook silva-braga has the story and so
just the walking is enough to tell who
has the phone that's right all professor
Vishal Patel did was ask a student to
walk across campus at Rutgers University
then hand his phone to another student
who walked back but that little
difference in how they walk is enough
he's enough to identify with the person
he's walking to the phone's
accelerometer every smartphone has one
the walking looked like this you have
two different people walking in the same
tag but as you can see their signatures
are very different just two years ago in
Mission Impossible rogue nation this was
science fiction these cameras actually
know how the agent walks how he talks
how he moves but researchers like Patel
are making biometrics real and trying to
use them to make our devices more secure
okay so if I try to use the phone as if
the camera is already looking at me with
a process called active authentication
that constantly passively monitors the
user the phone was also trained
incredibly to recognize the unique way
it's owner Scrolls down the screen and
now if you were to switch the phone
let's say if you want to try losing his
phone so if I swipe is gonna be able to
tell it's someone else someone else is
crawling yes I know yes wipe this cause
like there you go in two swipes that's
amazing yeah after two swipes the swipes
the time between specific keystrokes
also gives you away so do the words you
choose and the way you punctuate them
move a mouse and the path of the pointer
can identify you
so can the way you click we saw a
promising results
one method works well enough but
combining several should as Google
showed in a 2015 test a new method of
authentication that may prove to be
tenfold more secure than the best
fingerprint sensors much of this work
has been funded by DARPA the research
group within the Department of Defense
angeles kira metis oversees the DARPA
project we have a lot of passwords and
as you've seen in the news we get
targeted the same as everybody else and
we think we can do something better than
passwords so this is self preservation
as much as anything that's right so
DARPA called on more than a dozen
universities and private companies for
creative solutions some are hard to
believe well your phone has a number of
radios Wi-Fi radio self cellular radio
Bluetooth radio these emit signals the
signals from a close-up distance reflect
off your skin well it turns out they
don't actually reflect off your skin
they actually penetrate the skin a few
millimeters so one of our performers
figured out a way of not only sensing
heartbeat but also extracting a high
fidelity signal that could be used to
authenticate the user based on their
individual heartbeat the phone can not
only hear our heart it knows whose heart
it is yes that's nuts it's fun so why
isn't this active authentication active
yet well it could drain our batteries
too quickly or fail to work in certain
settings for example the camera can't
see you in the dark and some of the
methods like tracking our pattern of
life could turn off users once you have
this information you can sort of learn
where the person will end up in the
afternoon or at night so a lot of people
this is just gonna look creepy that's
right it is creepy
but it is very very powerful what
guarantees me that somebody is not using
my biometric data to do surveillance on
me Joseph's addict helped invent facial
recognition technology 25 years ago but
today he says tracking users is so
valuable to marketers that tech
companies can't be trusted to
self-regulate their use of biometrics
you broke my password I'm gonna change
it can't change your face I can't change
my face I can't
my fingerprints I need some mechanism to
protect me that mechanism would be a
guarantee that all the biometric
information stays on the device for CBS
this morning Saturday brook silva-braga
New York all right so this can't get
here fast enough
that's what's he over/under number of
times a year you change your password
because you can't remember I just did it
twice yesterday on two different sites
are you kidding occur yeah the only
thing I'm thinking though is I use my
thumb on my phone the number of times
where that doesn't work and I have to
put in the password because it's just
not clicking I guess if it's recognizing
your face it would do that automatic
number of times I've had to call my kids
into the room to fix it like even that
you can't get done